is there anything that kara does that
just drives you like insane
um
when kara drinks
yeah a lot and some point she just want
just like keep going and never stop
right and so bad to say that every time
that you drink
i know almost exactly how you're gonna
end how does it end drunk
not remembering what happened the last
night i probably remember the beginning
of it the beginning
but i would love to enjoy the whole
thing
cara is a very social person she enjoys
going out with friends going out like
usually entails cocktails or a bottle of
wine she definitely lives her life like
on kara's terms
do you guys feel like we fight more when
kara's drinking absolutely
many times we had that conversation and
at the end of the conversation she was
telling me something like
i will change i will be better
there's always room for improvement yeah
um but i mean what if she
just
wants to like keep going i won't tell
her that she cannot do it but definitely
she will have to understand that also i
will have a layman
sometimes she know
what makes me feel uncomfortable and she
still wants to do it
like if we go out and i say hey i want
to go back home
i never want to go back she never want
to go back home
why do we got to be the first ones to go
home i hate being the first people to
leave a party
like when i when i go out i'm like
having such a good time and i love to
talk to people and i'm like having fun
and da da da da da
but it's you know a learning curve
[Music]
you